i'll give you a little bit of a big
[Music]
fight
[Music]
[Music]
and literally two doors down
hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
welcome back to my channel and i've got
a fantastic interview with katie from
ko estates you may know who she is she's
going crazy at the moment across
instagram and on tiktok making some
viral videos
and she's going to be sharing exactly
how she has sold
30 property investment deals aged just
22 in the last 12
weeks absolutely incredible hey do me a
favor though before we get started
you know what to do smash the like
button subscribe to the channel
and uh casey thank you so much for
coming down it's been a pleasure
i loved seeing your project you got
going on so this is the first time we've
ever met
yeah we've obviously we've spoken on the
phone and we're familiar with each other
on on social media and stuff like that
but um you know massive achievement 30
deals i mean i couldn't not invite you
for an interview
when you've done 30 deals in 12 weeks
it's been insane
yeah and all fun and games you know what
really freaks me out is the fact that
you haven't even quit your job yet
no we're still hustling side hustle
long days early mornings late nights so
you've done all that alongside
a job yes which is insane so how did all
this get started
well um when did it get started about
uh over a year ago it kind of started as
a property blog
i was buying my own house to live in and
while i was doing all the research i was
like
i may as well put this content out on a
blog for people to read and to be honest
there probably wasn't that many people
reaching it
um and it really grew from there so it
was kind of
in lockdown bit board didn't have that
much to do so we really started to
concentrate more time on it
and they like the first probably project
i worked on was the like house in the
nhs so it was the first lockdown
and the i saw a need basically there was
um nhs staff that wanted somewhere to
stay in the pandemic so they weren't
bringing
all the germs and everything back from
the hospital somewhere they could study
and self-isolate so they can still go to
work
and i knew there was a lot of landlords
that had empty properties
and they were
like they were happy to donate them
basically for a good cause i
feel like everyone was really trying to
do the bit at the time and so we were
really just matchmaking
the empty properties and the
nhs staff that wanted to help and then
so that's where i really started to grow
and network
and really build on what i've built
already cool so you saw this
this need you saw the situation that was
going on with the nhs
how did that then result in you
packaging property
investments and selling them what's the
link yeah so it was just kind of like
the starting point
of the journey and i was like i'm
actually really
enjoy that this industry and i know from
like watching a lot of your videos you
can
make a lot of money in property and
there are a lot of creative ways around
that that you can do it without having
money yourself
yeah and so i then started to grow my
social pages my blog i was posting on
there every week
um and then it was really kind of the
back end of the year the start of this
year
um where i put on a reel
and it was kind of explaining to the
audience like this is what we bought it
for
this is um how much it took to do it all
up and this is what it solved for and
the video kind of just went
nuts and we've got so many views and so
many people they're messaging going
oh my god i want one especially a lot of
our clients are down south because they
see the prices in the north
and the higher yields and rate on return
and they were just like this is insane
like a property that
like that would cost like half a mil
where i'm from and so it went really
popular on social media and
a lot of people were reaching out like
please help me find one
um and then that's where really i
started
deal sourcing and then looking for
properties
to then sell on to investors so we're
growing our email lists and and
growing the platform and moving from
there so ko estates
it doesn't stand for knockout estates it
stands for
ktr which is your name yeah and the
company is your company
yes you so it's solely owned by you yeah
your dad is a property investor right
yes and again like
it's so interesting to see because
people will always try and when they see
someone winning
they'll try and think of a reason as to
why that person's winning and why
they're not
yeah so your dad's a property investor i
know he's got i don't know how many buy
to let's but what what
is he is he a big-time investor uh he's
got about 60. okay 60.
oh wow so he's a big-time investor yeah
yeah i didn't know he was that big time
right
so so your dad's a property investor
he's killing it he's got 60 properties
you see this need with the nhs thing
going on you then do a little video and
you just in one of your dads buy to
let's
it was bought for this much the rent is
this much boom it goes
crazy you get loads of these southerner
investors reaching out to you
at the meantime you're watching my
videos
your brother is like 17 and he's been
watching me since he was
13 or something yeah he was the one
that's like sent me the link to all your
stuff
and i think we were on like holiday and
he sent me this link and he was like
check this guy out he's so cool
and so that's where i first saw all your
stuff
and um obviously i'd been around my
parents who had been in it before but
they it always seemed to me you needed
money to then
get into property right but seeing your
videos i was like hang on like this is
such a creative way around it there's
ways that i can get it into it at a
young age without
having like big deposits and things
myself and ironically
you've now saved up your deposit to buy
your own buy to let yeah
by doing deal sourcing yeah which is
just amazing so mad congrats
also it's good to see your brother now
getting in on the business um
who i'm gonna i'm gonna give him a shout
out tom because he didn't introduce us
together or introduce you to my videos
but he filmed your first
video for social media yeah which went
viral videographer
[Music]
yeah massively good so okay so you start
was what was the when did you first take
your first
fee off somebody and what tell me the
story about that um
so it was kind of towards the back end
of march
um we started like
really advertising properties from the
start of march
um and we were growing an email list i
had like an investors club
and through socials we were saying um
if you like the type of things we do
sign up for our
link and we'll send you our deals our
latest deals out
and so that's how we were kind of
building up client base
um all through social media like we
didn't do any advertising or anything
um and then just kind of grew from there
reached out and then
so people who like the look of their
properties will then get in touch we'll
have a conversation
and you can tell pretty quick if they're
like serious or not and obviously
all our deals at the moment are tenanted
and so we don't like to
take people into the properties unless
they are really serious about
it because otherwise the tenant is
living in that property that you don't
want every weekend you've having
yeah exactly and i'm just trying to work
out like at what point because
i mean honestly katie 30 deals
that you have and you've actually sold
these deals not all necessarily
completed but you've taken money off the
investors right
30 deals in the last 12 weeks that's a
lot
that's a lot of deals so i'm just trying
to work out did you
decide i'm going to have a machine of a
deal source in business and sell a lot
of deals
or did it just sort of happen
accidentally was this a master plan or
is this just being a
it just happened so it was kind of like
the videos we didn't expect to get that
response from
um and then once we saw that response i
was like
we can really monetize this and i can
really like
make it into something that i really
want to do and so then it became a lot
more strategic and
getting everything in place to to
to scale up what does your dad think
as a old-school buy-to-letter investor
seeing
you make so much money from selling
deals like what does he think about
everything
it kind of blows his mind a bit more
yeah he was like what
i think um especially to like first-time
investors as well like
sourcing fees aren't always what you
hear others suppose like if you've not
done it before you just know buying
property through an estate agent and you
don't ever
pay a sourcing fee yeah so um like that
side of things were new and
people were like why am i charging what
am i paying you 2 thousand pounds for
um to like secure the deal but we do do
a lot of like due diligence on the
property we've got the local knowledge
we add um a lot of value to make sure
that they're buying right
to make sure it's an investment that's
going to see them through
yeah and i guess as well the estate
agent when an estate agent sells you a
deal
they're obliged to work on behalf of the
seller exactly yeah whereas when you're
a deal sourcer
you're working for the buyer yeah so
you're trying to get the best deal
so it's buying from an estate agent
they'll sell you anything
exactly and then so we are charging a
fee for our service but
we're um negotiating so hard to get them
the best
deal and the best rate of returns that
often the money we're saving for them
well outweighs the sourcing fee that we
charge so yeah it pays for itself okay
so tell me about the last deal that you
sold give me the figures
okay so um we sold one for
80 000. yeah and i think
it was on the market for 85 000
and so we've we got that reduced down
and the client that bought it
put down a 25 deposit yeah um
so about 20 grand about 20 000
interest-only mortgage
and the rates are quite good at the
moment um i think it's like
roughly 100 pounds for the mortgage each
month the rent is 520 a month
so it's kind of like 400 pound profit so
it's just like a really solid
yeah you know property you've not you've
not five grand off the price
yeah you've found the letting agent and
then this and
like a packaged ready-made yeah there's
no work that needs to be done the
tenant's already in place so as soon as
you complete you're starting to make
like your rental incomes coming in
straight away what's been the biggest
struggle
oh um
like time time
and making sure i'm doing everything to
like the standard i'd want it to do
yeah um and yeah i
i just want to give the best service and
to do that like
i want to spend so long on the phone
with everyone like you become such good
friends and like
really invested in their journey um and
following all that through
so yeah it's um it's exciting but
how do you deal with investors that are
super demanding or maybe it's their
first time and they're just asking you a
ton of questions but you don't know if
they're actually serious
whether they be you know there might be
great people but could be slightly time
wasters or
troublesome investors how do you how do
you deal with those people
yeah it's hard because like i
get on with so many people and i'm like
when i really buy into them
but i think you can you can really tell
from like a couple of questions at the
start like
um so if we're if we're marketing a
property at 80 000. like
have you got a 20 000 pound deposit
because realistically you are gonna need
that to
kind of get the deal over the line and
some people
are first-time investors and that's like
absolutely fine
we love following the journey so some
some
someone who completed this week um who
we secured a deal with
i was speaking to them six months ago
and they were like i love what you do
tell me what i need to be able to get
there so we like had a conversation i
was like okay so you need your deposit
you need to
you want to set up a limited company and
get kind of got all your ducks in a row
and then he was like i've got all that
ready um
what have you got available so we went
through the best options got one sorted
and he's secured this week so like it's
a six month journey
um but it was just so nice to like
follow that through
and from like start to end and know that
you've really helped someone is so wrong
that's great
and i saw you the way you faced it when
you said that the deal completed this
week or last week
you know it's a great feeling yeah um
what about do sometimes
investors not want to pay up front
because i know you
take a fee up front right yeah got all
of the fee up front but you take
half of it up front how do
investors react when you ask for that
thousand pound deposit upfront
um we've had mixed responses i think
from
people that are new to investing in that
source and
they've never heard of a sourcing fee
before they can be like wait what's this
for and what am i getting for it
um but i think when you build up the
trust with them
you're chatting with them and you just
to explain it's really to
and just secure that deal like we've
done 30 and 12 weeks that they are
flying
flying out and just in order for them to
secure it and we say it as yours and
market is sold on the website and we
really just have to do that because
you can kind of get weeks down the
purchasing process and then they can
pull out and it's just like you're back
to square one so we just
kind of do that to protect ourselves and
themselves so
as soon as they've paid that we will not
let anyone else touch it go near it
it's theirs yeah what happens if they
pay a thousand pounds
and then the deal falls through or they
pull out or or something happens
which which is common right that's not
unheard of it can happen
so um it depends so it's a
non-refundable deposit
unless it's a mistake on on behalf
um so we would if it was a mistake on
our behalf would absolutely give that
back
no problems at all but to say if we
advertise their property incorrectly or
said something it wasn't
um then i don't think that's
unreasonable for them
to want that money back and to like i'd
want the same
guarantee going into it myself so so
basically you have terms and conditions
and depending on what the reasons were
of the deal falling through
yeah um would depend on the outcome but
that's given up front before i pay
anything
yeah okay great so what's been the most
exciting part when did you
when did the penny drop that holy moly
i've got a great business here
kind of on um like social um
and like that side of things has just
like completely
changed the game i think like property
in general
um estate agencies can be quite um
not on social media and not you like
utilizing
that like i think i was i was saying
like i
buy dresses on instagram i buy
like anything on instagram like so many
brands are selling there now like why
wouldn't you buy a house
yeah and so that was kind of where it
first originally came from
like we need to really like use
social media everyone's on the phones
all the time and it's just like a way to
get in front of
the the right people yeah what is the
response been as well from estate agents
do estate agents get it or do you have
to educate them in terms of
you've got this property and i'm going
to negotiate it on behalf of an investor
and say it's the investor i mean
what's the reaction with estate agents
we've had really mixed responses
um some absolutely love what they do
what we're doing
especially on social and like the
advertising side because they can pay
thousands on advertising each year
and we've like not paid a penny um just
because like the reach so
some some are like you need to teach us
how to do this and i reach
reach more people um and then we've kind
of got to the stage where estate agents
are coming to us saying we've got these
properties that we
would like to help sell um and
so it's just like a great way to i guess
estate agents they might
say i've had this a million times um you
know oh you need to show us how you're
doing this
but they will never be able to do it
because they're getting paid by the
seller yeah you can't get paid by the
seller
exactly it's a conflict whereas we're
operating for the investor
you know and that's why we're only if i
said to you i've got a property it's
three hundred thousand pound house and
the rent's 1200 you'd go
good for you but i'm not selling it to
my guys yeah because that's only going
to give me a five percent return on
investment and my guys are looking for a
15
or whatever it might be so um you know i
think i think i think it's a great
service
i think that being a deal source of as
long as you are
an ethical deal source or it's a shame
because you do get people out there that
try and package and sell deals but they
do it wrong or they'll
just try and make a quick book and then
it gives the industry a bad name which
is why
i think it's really important that
people that's why i put out so many
videos
yeah i play about adding value yeah i
put out so many videos saying
this is how you do it you need to have
these insurances you need to do
and i'll put up videos trying to train
people have training programs
um so that people do it the right way
rather than just
um try and make a quick buck yeah i
don't know what you think about that
yeah no like totally agree i think but i
think that's with any industry you can
get people that are just cheating the
system or
um like not doing what they say they're
doing so um
yeah i think you're always gonna get
that but it doesn't give
it doesn't give you like the industry a
great name and can like
tarnish and tarnish that but
it's um something you've got to build up
trust with and i think that's why the
content is so valuable because
people are watching you for months
before they invest in you yeah
or in some cases they're watching me
when they're kids like your brother yeah
yeah you know
watching me what do you mean when you
said that i've been watching since 2017.
i'm like but you're only
17. you know um okay cool
so so the province that you're buying
now yeah your buy to let
tell me about it so it is a
two up two down in blackpool it's um
part uh it's like one of the properties
that we had advertised
up for so like i am buying the deals
that we're finding
you advertised did anyone buy it and
well it didn't make it to the website
because i thought
oh right that's the thing when you're a
deal saucer you're almost getting paid
to view houses
yeah getting paid to find the best deals
yeah so you found it looking for
yourself but you didn't put it on the
website
yeah so um i snatched that one up and
um yeah so it's gonna be around
80 000 mark again with the 20 000 pound
deposit
um and bringing in about
420 a month after mortgage and
everything and are you putting that 20
grand down solely from the money that
you've made from
sourcing deals for other people yeah
what a brilliant way i know
what a brilliant way um okay so once
you've got this by to let
are you planning on building your own
portfolio over the years is that what
you're planning on doing yeah definitely
want to kind of scale up and grow um
and get to a place where
that's like financially free and it's
all yeah because
because packaging and selling deals is
is great money yeah but it's not passive
no so what you're doing definitely no
it's not so what you're doing is you're
making
active income yeah it's not passive but
maybe it's massive
right active income and then you're
putting the profits into something
that's going to make you a passive
income
and then slowly over time you're going
to become financially free yeah but i
mean
hey um i'm sure a lot of people would
trade places with you at 22 years old
you might not be
financially free but being able to make
the class of money that you are at 22
um you know is is absolutely incredible
what do your friends think
like your friends school buddies
whatever what's the reaction been
um i think it's really cool like um
a lot of like really tried to help and
go out the way to help and
um but yeah at the moment because it's
just so busy i feel like
i'm spending so much time on ko that
i've got to
like really make time for the people
that are supporting me and getting me to
where i am as well because that's so
important
yeah and how do you deal because i know
when you're on the internet like
you you're in thousands of views on your
instagram
um how do you deal with the negativity
like i
am a 30 year old man i've got a very
thick skin
you know i'm making crazy good money so
for me i kind of don't mind that much
everyone's human
you're a young lady you're getting crazy
views some of your videos are like
going bigger than my videos it must come
with some negativity and if so
how do you deal with that yeah like you
get so many comments both like good and
bad
um like it really doesn't affect me that
much
um you're not gonna please everyone like
one of our videos got
1.5 million hits like
if you've got all those people in the
room they're not going to agree on
everything so you
you've just kind of you've got to
just like let those people have their
opinions and
at the end of the day you don't need all
those people to be your clients and you
don't want all those people to be the
clients the ones that are giving you
negativity so
and like the the people we were dealing
with
we got on like we're almost like friends
with
a lot of them like we'll meet for the
dinner and stuff like we got out so well
um that like the negative ones almost
become
irrelevant right um and obviously the
comments help the algorithm so
that's a very commercial way to look at
it katie rather than a
human away because because generally
speaking though humans you know you
might put a video out
you're gonna get you get nine people
saying awesome video great job and then
one person says something negative
um but but the human brain will focus on
that one
yeah that's most people but i think you
know it's great that you've got
that commercial mindset to be able to
actually doesn't matter and i think
what really matters is what your
customers are saying yeah if your
customers are happy
um and in my case you know my staff i
think my with my customers
my staff my family my church me
and god if we're happy then i'm not
really too interested in whatever
anybody else has to say because i'm not
accountable to them i'm accountable to
my customers and my staff
but i don't think social media is for
everybody
no it's definitely not i think if you're
the type of person that's going to read
into all those negative ones
it's not a great place if that's what
you're putting out but i think if you
you are putting
things out you've got to expect expect
it and
and yeah to a degree yeah yeah yeah and
i i also think just generally in
business not just on social media yeah
like you're making great money now do
you do your your property sourcing but
if you're in business and you're making
good money
you're gonna get people that don't
necessarily like it um
i mentioned earlier about your dad's got
60 properties you know some people even
on this video might say
it's only because her dad's in property
that she's but but it's like well look
everybody is born into this world with a
different set of cards
and what you need to do you need to take
the cards that you've been dealt and you
need to deal
on the best that you can life is
ninety percent what you make it but ten
percent how you take what you've already
got
and um you know what you've done is
you've utilized
your situation but your dad didn't even
know what deal sorting was
yeah you know and like i'm so grateful
for the upbringing i have both parents
have like
been like such a big part and like
teaching me so much about
it and but at the same time still got to
be quite resourceful i wasn't just given
like money to go and buy and sell my own
portfolio
and and so i was resourceful with the
knowledge that i had
yeah yeah you made the money and now
you're investing in it so
i'm super excited to see that so if
someone wants to get in touch with you
if they want to follow you on instagram
tic tac uh if they want to talk to you
about doing business together whatever
it might be
um what's the best way to reach out
definitely
check out our social pages we've got ko
estates on instagram and tick tock
and ko estates.com
awesome our website as well great hey
congratulations keep up the great work
and it's been a real pleasure and it's
been honestly so good to see you winning
oh thank you you too you know awesome
hey guys i hope you enjoyed that
interview with katie from ko estates
absolute smash net 22 years old let me
ask you a question
what is your excuse property is an
incredible asset
if you learn how to find good deals then
you find investors marry the two
together
there's no reason why you can't stop
making quick good income and then use
that
to invest into property yourself and
build your own portfolio if you want to
learn
more about how to learn these skills of
course you can subscribe to the youtube
channel where i put out a youtube video
every single day and you can subscribe
up here
also if you want to come and meet me in
person you want to come down to some of
our free training
you can do that i'll leave a link up
here don't forget to watch more videos
and i look forward to seeing you guys
next time
[Music]
you